heute nacht ist der perfekte start einer
hammer weltraum mission gelungen bp
colombo klingt irgendwie nach
kinderprogramm ist es aber nicht es geht
um die erforschung des sonnennächsten
planeten und das ist eine riesige
herausforderung denn eigentlich kann man
gar nicht zum merkur fliegen die sonne
zieht jeden flugkörper stärker an als
der merkur doch mit einem trick soll es
gelingen wie das funktioniert jetzt im
blick zum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen
wir hatten hier ja schon mal sogar
berichtet uns entgeht halt nichts jetzt
noch mit mehr infos und dem aktuellen
geschehen von gestern
merkur ist mit einem durchmesser von
knapp 4900 kilometer nur ein bisschen
größer als der erde mond und damit der
kleinste planet des sonnensystems
dementsprechend gering ist auch seine
gravitation was zu problemen führt dazu
gleich er ist der sonnennächste planet
und durch die europäische panische
mission bepicolombo wenn man nicht nur
erkenntnisse zur entstehung des gesamten
sonnensystems bekommen sondern zu den
erdähnlichen terrestrischen planeten
überhaupt doch das ganze gestaltet sich
gar nicht so einfach denn es gibt noch
eine herausforderung in der merkur
umlaufbahn ist die sonneneinstrahlung
achtung zehnmal höher als auf der erde
und das müssen instrumente und
satelliten auch erst einmal überstehen
bis zu 450 grad heiß wird es auf der
merkur oberfläche und eine weitere
herausforderung stellt die anreise da
denn der merkur ist im gegenteil zum
mars oder zur venus nur durch ein
langwieriges ab bremsmanöver erreichbar
konkret wird die sonde die
gravitationskraft vom merkur venus und
erde nutzen um durch neuen manöver den
absturz ins sonnensystem innere
abzubrennen immer wieder muss die sonne
an erde venus und schließlich mehrmals
am merkur vorbeifliegen um abgebremst zu
werden und auch seine umlaufbahn
einschwenken zu können sieben jahre lang
dauert deswegen der anflug die baby
colombo besteht aus zwei satelliten zum
einen aus dem japanischen mercure mac
notos feric peter mmo und zum zweiten
aus dem europäischen märkte planetary
orbiter mp
beide werden auf unterschiedlichen
umlaufbahnen unterwegs sein um den
merkur zu erforschen
die japanische sonde wird sich vor allem
seinen magnetfeld worden und auch dessen
wechselwirkung mit dem sonnenwind
untersuchen die europäische sonde soll
dagegen auf einer niedrigeren umlaufbahn
unterwegs sein und die innere
zusammensetzung des planeten erforschen
konkret sollen unter anderem die
folgenden fragen beantwortet werden ist
der kern des merkur fest oder flüssig
ist der planet tektonisch aktiv also
gibt es am mehrere kontinentalplatten
wie bei uns und wir sind die krater an
den polen beschaffen die permanent im
dunkeln liegen dort könnte es nämlich
gefrorenes eis geben und damit selbst
dort im umfeld die chance auf leben
gestern ist die mission mit einer
ariane-5-rakete vom weltraumbahnhof
kourou gestartet und hat ein erstes
signal zur erde geschickt alle symbolen
bereich erste ergebnisse gibt es aber
erst ab 2025 wir sind gespannt wenn ihr
dazu und zu allen anderen themen kein
video verpassen wollt dann endet meine
handynummer auf whatsapp dann werdet ihr
immer informiert wenn ein video online
geht und zwar als erstes dafür einfach
hier klicken und ein kleines geschenk
habe ich auch noch zur begrüßung und
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken noch mehr super spannende
missionen die spektakulärste
weltraummissionen heißt das video bis
dann bleibt dran